- Awesome, so welcome everyone
to another episode of
D4P, Data for the People.
And this is our COVID-19 series,
and so our goal is to
provide the science for all
straight from the source,
and today I'm gonna be presenting a paper
that talks about the human
antibody responses to SARS-COV-2.
Before we get started, I do
wanna take a moment of silence
in lieu of George Floyd who
lost his life unfortunately
to cop brutality.
As a black scientist,
it would behoove me not
to take the time out
to recognize that this is still happening,
and it's really hard a lot of times for us
as minorities to separate
ourselves from our professions.
And so I just want us
to take about 10 seconds
just to remember his life.
Awesome, thank you guys.
There's so much more I would
like to say about this,
but I think we'll go
straight into the science.
So once again, for those who don't know,
I am always make a big
stink about where I'm from,
so I'm actually from the
United States, Virgin Islands,
so a US territory, more specifically
I'm from the large Island of St. Croix,
we're actually only 84 square miles
about 60,000 in population.
And once again, I'm just gonna showcase
one of our beautiful beaches,
and the weather today as you
can see I'm in my backyard,
but I would much rather
it be a beach background.
Here's my little family,
my husband is on vacation,
so he's actually watching our son,
and this is him helping
me with my presentation
which actually almost
went haywire this morning
when he spilled coffee on my laptop.
But that's a story for another day,
all as well so we'll keep it moving.
All right, so a little
bit about the publications
that scientists put out.
So publications is
basically a central source
where we can communicate
our research findings
and it happens in a variety of ways,
the problem is a lot of these
reports are topic specific
and very jargon specific.
And so it's really hard
for a lot of people outside of the field
to kind of depict exactly
what's the conversation is on
or what the data is showing.
And so the paper I'm presenting today
is actually one from a
peer reviewed article,
and so this article is
"Nature of Medicine"
and what peer reviewed mean
is that it's evaluated by
other scientists in the field
and it's seen as a report
that is fleshed out properly,
all the datasets look fine
and then it's published.
So we talk about through
all the D4P presentations
about the styles of scientific reasoning.
This paper looks into
experimental evaluation,
and so that's using investigations
to establish different patterns,
to look for differences
or to develop hypothetical model.
So for example, in this paper,
we're looking at the timing
of antibody responses in patient samples.
So here's a screenshot of the paper.
So like I mentioned, it's
from "Nature Medicine"
and this paper is entitled
antibody responses to SARS-CoV-2
which is the virus that gives you
the disease COVID-19 in patients.
Now, what's really
fascinating about this paper
is that they're not just one nor 10,
they're actually about
50 authors on this paper.
Just highlighting again
the collaborative effort that it takes
for scientists to put together datasets
that can be produced in a
platform, what can be used
to initiate different
public health initiatives.
Now throughout my presentation,
I'm gonna talk about
a number of key terms.
So one of those terms I'm gonna mention
is antibodies and antigen,
I'm also gonna talk about seroconversion
as well as aggregate and
individual data points.
And so just a brief
background on how the body
elicits an immune response to SARS-CoV-2.
So the virus SARS-CoV-2 as seen here,
it's an RNA virus which
you see in the center
and it's protected by a lipid bilayer.
Within that lipid bilayer,
there are a number of different proteins,
but there are also these surface proteins,
in this case, it's spike protein
that not only elicit our
immune response to the virus,
but is also necessary for binding
to the receptor on your cell
in order for entry and
replication to occur.
Now, once the virus binds the
cell and enters and replicate,
it can cause an immune response.
So not only is an immune
response initiated
towards the surface proteins,
but an immune response can
be made from the proteins
that protect the RNA,
like nuclear proteins
or other proteins within
the matrix of the virus.
Now our immune system is very complex,
and I'm only gonna talk about
one part of the immune system,
which is adaptive immunity,
but there's also innate immunity
which is like the first line
of defense, it's nonspecific,
it just targets and tries
to eliminate anything
that's foreign inside of the body.
Unlike, innate immunity,
adaptive immunity,
recognize specific antigens.
So what occurs, we have a
virus which is a pathogen,
so in this case we have SARS-CoV-2,
SARS-CoV-2 enters our cells, replicates,
our body recognizes it
as something foreign,
and so that foreign antigen
triggers an immune
response within your body.
And so that immune response
can go on to do several things.
And so the immune response basically
recognizes this pathogen
and recognizes certain
parts of the pathogen
which we call antigens.
And so you can either
elicit an immune response
where different cells have
certain receptors on there
to bring about many other immune
cells to combat infection,
or we can make these
and or we can make these
specialized molecules called antibodies
that is used to protect us in the future.
Now these antibodies are fairly specific,
so they recognize specific
parts of the antigen
where they combine and
eliminate infection.
And so the paper that I'm
gonna talk about today
focuses on this part
of the immune response
which is a production of antibodies
that's specific to SARS-CoV-2.
So how does the antibody-antigen work?
And so within adaptive immunity,
you have a number of different antibodies
that are produced by the human body.
There are actually five
different types of antibodies.
We have IgM, IgG, IgD, IgE and IgA.
For our purposes today,
I'm only gonna focus on two antibodies
that I'm gonna talk
about in the next slide.
But these antibodies recognizes
different parts of the virus.
So here's SARS-CoV-2
after it enters the cell.
And so these antibodies that are produced
can then bind specific parts of the virus,
and in this case, the spike protein
and work to either
recruit other immune cells
to get rid of infection
or neutralize the virus
so that it doesn't infect your cells.
So what are these two major antibodies
that seems to be implicated
in SARS-CoV-2 infection?
So we have IgM, so IgM is
one of the first antibodies
to come into play.
Your body encounters a foreign
antigen or foreign particle,
it recognizes that it
does not belong there.
And so IgM actually
exists off of the cell,
so if it's not on a cell as a receptor,
it exists alone as a pentamer.
So a pentamer is just
meaning five molecules
linked together, and once these molecules
enter the bloodstream,
it sends messages to the
rest of the immune system
to produce other antibodies,
and in this case,
it usually produces, helps
to produce IgG antibodies.
Now IgG antibodies are the
most abundant in antibodies
where you can detect
in humans blood samples
within the serum.
And so IgG exists as a
monomer, meaning one molecule.
All right, so our first poll,
which antibody type is thought
to provoke long term immunity
in humans to COVID-19?
IgM, IgG, IgD or IgE?
Give you a couple of seconds to answer.
You have five more seconds.
Awesome, so let's see what you thought.
All right, so 48% thought it was IgG,
coming into a close second is IgM,
what about 36% of the vote?
So the majority actually wins.
And so it's actually thought
that IgG is the antibody
that is thought to provide immunity
for a next infection to that same virus.
All right, so one of those key terms
I'm gonna talk about right
now, which is seroconversion.
What is seroconversion?
So seroconversion is that time point
where you go from being
undetectable for a specific antibody
to being able to detect that antibody
within that patient's blood sample.
And so here on this graph,
we have on the y-axis,
we have the time course of infection
and then on the left we
have the amount present.
So usually it takes some
time from being infected
for our bodies to seroconvert
to producing a certain
amount of antibodies.
So you can say at this time point,
this patient seroconverted IgM antibodies
and at this time point, they
seroconverted IgG antibodies.
And I'll talk a lot more
about seroconversion
in the presentation.
Now another thing that
this study points out
is the different types
of datasets that we have.
And so we can either look at
datasets as aggregate data.
And so this involves many
different data points,
it can show trends and comparisons
using statistical analysis,
but it doesn't look at the individual.
And so that's where individual
data comes into play.
And so sometimes when we're
looking at aggregate datasets,
there might be individuals
that may respond slightly differently.
And so a lot of times scientists
zone into the individual
to try to figure out how we can develop
personalized approaches
to that person's response.
And so what's the question?
Like what did this paper go in to describe
and try to answer?
And so there's a lot of,
there's not much information on there
on exactly how our antibodies
respond to COVID-19
or how the immune system
responds to COVID-19.
And so this is a graph, I've
also used this the last time
when I was describing the tests
that we use to develop antibodies.
And so there are still some questions
that we're trying to understand.
So one of the first goals
that authors look into
is when do we see seroconversion
and how long does it last?
So when can we see or when can we detect
IgM antibodies in a patient's sample?
When can we detect IgG
antibodies in a patient's sample?
How long does the presence of IgM occurs?
And also how long does IgG stay
after someone is infected with COVID-19?
But the authors also wanted
to look at something else.
So we also try to, the
authors also try to decide
if antibody testing can
complement viral testing.
And so I briefly mentioned it,
but in the beginning you can actually use
a specific test called RT-PCR.
And I want this right,
but now, but if you want,
you can go back to Fran's D4P presentation
where she goes into detail
as to how scientists can
take the genetic information,
change it into a way that we
can detect it in a patient.
And so we use RT-PCR to detect
if there are any viral samples
or viral particles within that patient
who may be currently infected.
Another test that we use is
antibody testing such as ELISA,
which I've mentioned it
in the first D4P talks,
so feel free to also check that out.
And where we look at the presence
or absence of either of these antibodies.
So does someone have IgM antibodies,
do they have IgG antibodies?
Have they recovered from infection
or are they currently
infected with SARS-CoV-2?
So for this study, I'm gonna
describe the patient design
or how they were able to design the study
with the patients that they had.
So this is study incorporated 285 patients
from Chongqing, China, and
there were three hospitals
that they were able to get patients from.
Out of these 285 patients,
250 of them had some type
of epidemiological history.
So what that means is that these patients
either were residents of Wuhan,
recently have been to Wuhan
or have come into close contact
with a resident of Wuhan
or someone who have confirmed COVID-19.
Out of those 285 patients,
262 of them had clear symptom onset.
So what that means is that these patients
knew exactly when their symptoms began.
So they were hospitalized,
the doctor asks them their history
and they could have told the doctor,
I experienced fatigue or headache
or high fever at a certain day.
And out of that 285 patient
dataset, we have 70 of them
where the scientists were able to gather
multiple serum samples to
look at the seroconversion
that I'm gonna talk about
later in the presentation.
So one of the first questions
that the scientists ask are
when are antibodies produced
after someone's infected with SARS-CoV-2?
And so scientists are
looking at the presence
of these antibodies that
they're able to detect
after these patients
started having symptoms.
So what we're looking at
is when patients are
producing IgM antibodies
and when they're producing IgG antibodies,
and how long after their symptoms
are these antibodies being produced?
So to answer this question,
they used 262 patients,
of these patients, they
had 363 serum samples.
And so serum is just part of the blood
that are, we can detect the antibodies.
And so they have 363
because they have multiple
samples from certain patients
that I've described before.
Now from these samples,
they use a type of ELISA to
detect the presence of the IgG
or IgM antibodies.
And so what did they see?
So here in this graph I wanna
highlight a couple of things.
So let's zone in on the x-axis.
And so here we see the days
after the patients
started having symptoms.
So we have dataset from
about two to four days
post having symptoms to about 23 days
after they started having symptoms.
On the y-axis, what we're
looking at is a positive rate.
So how many of these
patients are we able to see
that detect, that we can
detect either IgM, IgG
or both of these antibodies.
So we're not looking at
the amount of antibodies
but just if they can detect it
or if they cannot detect it.
And so what we're seeing at about 20 days
after patients have symptoms,
you have about 94% of them
where you can detect the IgM antibodies.
And at about 17 days post symptoms onset
a 100% of the patients samples,
they were able to detect IgG antibodies.
But what this chart doesn't show us
is the amount of antibodies
present within these patients
that have contracted COVID-19.
And so next the scientists wanted to see
what the levels were of these antibodies
within these patients.
So for this dataset, we
are using 262 patients.
And so I'm gonna show you the
first dataset that they show
where on the bottom of the x-axis,
N is the number of patients
that they're assessing
under each time point,
above the N number, you have
the days after symptoms onset.
So here we have within the first week,
within the second week,
so on and so forth.
On the y-axis, we're looking
at the levels of antibodies,
and just a reminder
that this is a log scale
so it's exponentially more
as you go up the scale.
And so the authors also
do statistical analysis
to show a number of things.
So I also wanna point out
that this is an example
of aggregate data
that includes individual data points.
So all of these dots are
the individual patients,
but we're using statistics to
look at the median or the mean
of all of the data points together
so we can look at the aggregate
data or the data on a whole.
And so this box indicates the first
and third percentile of patients,
the bar within the middle of the box
look at the average of all
of those patients together,
and then we have the whiskers.
So anything outside of the whiskers,
we can't say that these
patients were outliers
within that sample set.
So this is IgG that we're
looking at, and what you can see
if we're looking at the
averages of all of the data
is that you see a continuous
increase in the levels
of IgG antibodies up to
about past three weeks
post symptoms onset.
So the authors also looked at the amount
of IgM antibodies levels in the patients.
And so what you see here, is on the bottom
we have the number of patients
that they're looking at
and the days after they
started having symptoms.
And so here you can see as well
when we're looking at IgG,
the averages of this aggregate data
you see a trend of an
increase of IgM antibodies
in terms of the levels that we're seeing,
and after three weeks you
start to see a slight decline
of that levels.
Once again, there are some
individual data points
that are outliers,
but in order to get a picture
of the population on a whole,
we have to use this aggregate dataset
to look at the averages so we can infer
how the population reacts
to a certain stimulus.
So overall this slide is showing
that we're seeing a slight decrease in IgM
after three weeks.
So what does this change what we know?
So in the first graph
that I've been presenting,
I'm showing that initially
you're seeing IgM
antibodies being detected,
and then you're seeing
IgG antibodies detected
with IgM decreasing as IgG increases.
Now this changes the graph a little.
So what we're starting to see is that
it seems that antibodies are
produced around the same time
and after about three weeks or so
you're seeing a slight decrease
in antibody levels for IgM,
but you're seeing a
continual increase in IgG,
and the authors also point out that
some of the patient's samples
started to remain steady
or plateau throughout the time point.
Now there's a lot of
talk about whether or not
a patient has a more
severe case of COVID-19
if they produce more antibodies
than someone who has a less
severe case of CIVID-19
or are asymptomatic to infection.
And so what the authors
do to combat this question
is that they looked at
a subset of patients
who they classified as severe.
So severe would be someone who's
been admitted into the ICU.
And so out of the patient
cohort, they had about 20
that they classified as having severe.
So the orange dots are severe cases,
the green are non-severe cases.
And you're also looking at the time
after the patient started having symptoms.
So here in this portion of the graph,
we're looking at the first week
after patients started to have symptoms,
and here we're looking at the second week
after they started to have symptoms.
Now this dataset shows
we're gonna zone in on the median
of this entire patient dataset,
and we're seeing that there
seems to be a trend of people
who have severe cases of COVID-19
have higher levels of IgG
antibodies being produced,
unlike those who have non-severe cases.
But also I wanna point out
if we were to zone in
on the individual data
that we do have some patients
who are also producing
large amounts of antibodies
and even though that they
don't have severe symptoms.
They looked at the same thing
post two weeks of symptoms onset
and you do see a slight
increase of antibodies produced
in comparison to those
who have non-severe.
The only significant
difference that they show
is within that first week with IgG.
And so what the P values indicate
is how much that this phenomenon
is occurring by chance,
and scientists pick a number
which is P equals 0.05,
and if that number is less than that,
we can say that the
chances of that happening
by random chance is very low,
and it actually does have something
to do with the phenomenon
that they're looking at.
The authors also looked at IgM.
And so here again, if
we're looking at the median
for each of the datasets, we
see within the first week,
you do see a slight increase
of the amount of antibodies
produced for severe patients,
and the same is true for those
post two weeks of symptoms onset.
Once again, this is a small dataset,
so we can only come up with conclusions
based on the sample size that we have.
So what did authors show so far?
So all of the patient's
samples that they've tested.
So looking at their serums
and looking for detectable antibodies,
100% of them produce IgG antibodies
about two to three weeks
after they started to have symptoms.
IgM antibodies, the
amount seems to decline
after about three weeks
of having symptoms,
and there seems to be a trend
where patients with severe symptoms
are producing slightly
higher levels of IgM and IgG
with significance
only seen in the first week post infection
with IgG antibody levels.
All right, so I'm gonna
dive in a little bit deeper
on the seroconversion of antibodies.
So I mentioned seroconversion
just means being negative
and being able to detect
either the IgM or IgG
in this case antibodies
in a particular patient.
So in order to combat these questions,
the scientists came up with
three different scenarios.
So the first is what we call
synchronous seroconversion.
And so what that means is
that you're able to detect
both IgG and IgM
antibodies at the same time
post the symptoms onset.
The next scenario is if
a patient produces IgM
earlier than IgG,
and this is kind of the
model that scientists use
for other viral infections
where IgM is being detected first,
followed by IgG antibodies
a couple of days after
they're able to detect IgM.
And the third seroconversion method is
whether or not you can
detect IgG antibodies
earlier than you can detect IgM.
So here you can detect
IgG, a few days later,
you can then detect IgM.
So another poll, which
version of seroconversion
do you think is occurring with patients
who've been infected with COVID-19?
Do you think it's
synchronous seroconversion?
Do you think it's IgM first and then IgG
or do you think it's IgG
first followed by IgM?
Give you a couple of seconds to answer.
Awesome, so we'll end the poll.
And so about 75% of the
audience thinks that IgM
are produced first and then IgG,
and then about 20% thinks it's
IgM and IgG being produced
or detected at the same time.
Now I'm not gonna tell you to answer,
I'm just gonna show you the data.
(laughs)
All right, so in order for the authors
to look at this seroconversion
that's happening,
it's a couple of things that they look at.
So they have 63 patients
and they're able to have serum samples
in three-day intervals.
Now out of those 63 patients,
96% of them were able to
seroconvert antibodies.
So they were able to
detect either IgG, IgM
or both of these antibodies.
But within that 63 patients,
they were able to gather 27 patients,
when they were hospitalized,
they were initially seronegative.
So what seronegative means
is that they are unable
to detect the presence
of IgG or IgM antibodies.
And so they took the sample
and these samples of patients
and they looked at when these patients
are producing either IgM or IgG.
All right, so let's see what
the scientists find out.
So now we're looking
at individual datasets.
So each dot again is looking
at each individual person
producing a certain type of antibodies.
So let's zone in on the x-axis.
So here we're looking at the
days after symptoms onset,
and on the y-axis, we're
just looking at the amount of
either the IgG or the IgM.
The red circles are IgG and
the blue triangles are IgM.
And so for 10 out of those 27 patients,
they're actually seen that
they're able to detect IgG
before they're able to detect IgM.
And the median days of seroconversion
where they can detect these
antibodies is about two weeks
or 13 days post symptoms onset.
And so what this will look
like is something like this
where you're seeing
or you're being able to
detect IgG antibodies
in comparison to IgM antibodies,
what happens a short time after.
Next, they were able to show
that nine out of those 27 patients
actually produced IgM and IgG
antibodies at the same time.
And so on the bottom of
the x-axis is the same.
So you're seeing about six
days after symptoms onset,
you have patients where you can detect
both of these antibodies.
Once again, seroconversion
of both of these antibodies
occur on average about 13 days,
and here's what that graph would look like
where you have the detectable levels
of IgM and IgG antibodies
occurring at the same time.
And then the patients,
the scientists had seven
of those 27 patients
actually produced or
seroconverted IgM antibodies
before they produced IgG antibodies.
Once again, the x-axis is the days
after the patients
started to have symptoms,
where you're able to
detect IgM in antibodies
and later you can detect the
IgG antibodies with 13 days
being that median date of seroconversion.
So this graph would
look something like this
where you're producing IgM antibodies
prior to IgG antibodies.
So the answer to the question
is that it happens differently
in different patients.
I think this is another
reason to point out
sometimes how individual datasets
actually a super important one
when we're looking at
approaches for medicines
I'm gonna move on to the second goal.
And so I've shown you
within the sample set
that the scientists have
when they're producing antibodies
and how these antibodies are seroconverted
within these patients.
But now that authors wanna ask,
how can serology testing
help identify COVID-19?
Now serology testing is
just a fancy way to say
that we're testing for the
presence of antibodies.
And so I just fine-tuned the graph
based on the data that I gave you.
Remember this is not really a one for all,
but this is just an depiction
of like the aggregate dataset.
And so on the bottom we have
the days post symptoms onset.
And so what you'll see in the beginning
once you have this viral infection,
you can test with RT-PCR,
and you can see if you
have levels of the virus
within that patient
to show that they're currently
infected with COVID-19.
Now a lot of times
patients only get tested
if they're having symptoms.
So you're feeling crummy,
one day the symptoms occur,
you're like, oh crap,
this might be COVID-19,
you get the viral tests, they
tell you that you're positive.
But I just wanna remind
you that there are patients
who actually never have symptoms, right?
The only times until recently
where patients would get tested
is if they've been into
close contact with patients
who had confirmed COVID-19.
So you have the asymptomatic patients
that may or may not get tested.
Now, if the test is super accurate,
you'll see that they tested positive
for the presence of
the virus in their body
by using the RT-PCR test.
But there are cases where you
can get false negative results
where the test can tell you
that you're negative for the virus,
but maybe in actuality you
actually contracted COVID-19
and you were symptomatic and
you did not know that you had
the presence of that virus in your body.
Now the serological test
is where we can look for IgM and IgG,
and looking at the presence
of these antibodies
can allow scientists to figure out
if a patient have the presence of IgM,
meaning that they have
been infected with COVID-19
or the presence of IgG,
meaning that there are currently infected
or they've recovered
from COVID-19 infection.
And so what these authors did
is look at a number of patients
who have come into close contact
with those who have confirmed COVID-19.
And so they have 164 of those patients,
and they took those patients
and they use the RT-PCR test
to look for the virus,
and out of those 164,
16 of them tested positive
using the RT-PCR test.
Out of those 16, 13 of
them were symptomatic,
so they had symptoms and three
of them were asymptomatic,
and all of them are tested
positive for IgG or IgM or both.
Now the scientist also did RT-PCR tests
on the rest of the patients,
and these patients had no symptoms,
and they also tested
negative by the RT-PCR test.
Now 30 days after they tested negative,
they gave all the patients
an antibody tests,
and to their surprise,
they were able to see that seven of them,
they were able to detect
IgG and or IgM antibodies
to SARS-CoV-2.
And so what this is saying is that
not only did we have 10 patients
out of the 164 close contacts
that were asymptomatic,
but the RT-PCR missed
about 4% of the patients
who actually did contract COVID-19.
So what lessons can we get from this
and what story does this tell?
And so it appears that scientists
are looking to initiate a way
that we can combine antibody
testing with RT-PCR tests
because it may be critical
to identify patients
who currently have COVID-19
and those who've recovered from infection.
And so if we're able to
complement the two testings,
this would allow us to increase
the accuracy for infection.
And so they also showed that
all the patients that they looked at
that were infected with COVID-19,
produced or seroconverted
detectable levels of IgG.
Now this IgG antibody
like I mentioned before,
is the antibody that scientists
think may infer immunity,
but we're still unsure as to
how long this immunity lasts.
And if you wanted to learn more about
if you can get reinfected,
I would like if you can
check out Joe's talk,
who talked about a study that
scientists did in macaques
where they were unable
to reinfect these monkeys
with SARS-CoV-2, but also
we wanna bear in mind
that this may not necessarily
translate to humans.
And they also showed that patients
produce IgM and IgG antibodies
that can be detected at
different time points
after they started having symptoms,
but on average, if we're
looking at the aggregate data,
it appears to be about two weeks
after you started having
symptoms to COVID-19.
And so I think this is great
that the study is telling us all of this,
but once again, with
every scientific article
and every experiment,
there are some limitations.
And so one, they did not test
for the presence of
neutralizing antibodies.
What are neutralizing
antibodies you ask?
And so these antibodies
basically have the ability
to bind that specific virus,
coat it so that it's
unable to infect the cells.
So it gets rid of the virus
even before it comes into
contact with your cells.
Even though we're producing antibodies,
the antibodies may also be necessary
for recruiting other cells
or other molecules to
get rid of infection,
but infection may already be taking place.
A new paper just came out in BioRxiv,
so this is a preprint.
It came out of Rockefeller
University, my employer.
And so what they're showing
is that the patients that they looked at,
so these are all patients
in New York City,
this dataset that I'm showing you today
are all patients from China,
and from the dataset
that they're looking at,
it appears that only a few people
who've been affected with SARS-CoV-2
are producing high amounts
of neutralizing antibodies,
but it doesn't mean that we're not,
the others are not producing any at all,
it just might be a minute
amount of antibodies
that they're unable to
detect in the laboratory.
So feel free to check out that paper.
Also, I just wanna pinpoint
that the sample size of
this study is fairly small,
so we only look at about 280 patients
for a lot of the data that I showed you,
but even when we're looking at
severe versus critical patients,
they were only about 20
that we classified as severe and critical.
And so even though it would show the trend
with the aggregate data,
we're still unsure as to how the antibody
correlates with the clinical
course of infection.
And also this does not look at
the changes in antibody responses
for a prolonged period of time.
Remember the scientists
only had the ability
to test patients who were hospitalized,
and so once they were able
to leave the hospital,
they're unable to test them,
so even though we are
producing IgG antibodies,
and they also showed other data
where they seemed to be
like the IgG antibodies are plateauing,
we can't really say anything
for past about 25 days
post symptoms onset
because the authors
did not look into that.